Aslan his name means lion
how are you the doctor says my love
open your eyes for me he's saying
and despite the most horrific injuries
arsalan is living up to his name he is
the sole survivor in his family both his
parents and his two older siblings died
in the earthquakes
[Music]
let's get going come on his uncle izat
hasn't left his bedside since he was
pulled out
mine he offers him some water
but arslan can only cough in response
his body's taken a battery he's not
drinking or eating
ah Yeti answers with soft murmurs
his uncle is begging him to be strong
he has terrible Crush injuries to both
legs the doctor says he may need both
amputated
he'll certainly never be the same again
the fact he's here at all is a miracle
we make no apologies for this video
being upsetting it is gruesome but this
is the reality the bodies of aslan's
siblings had already been found by this
point
but this is arsalan's Father Solomon
his dying Act was to use his body to
Shield his youngest child
as he's pulled out you can see arsalan's
arm poking through the stones he's
wearing striped pajamas
he's the last to be recovered they hope
against hope he's alive
then as he's dragged out of the rubble
they realize he is
his eyes flicker open unbelievably he's
made it
he is alive only because of his father's
love but it's just one of many battles
ahead for the toddler
the Medics trying to save him insist the
four-day delay by the United Nations and
sending Aid to Northwest Syria is
responsible for his suffering
[Music]
and they blame everyone who contributed
to that slow response
boy
don't give them the
care that they need
their energy and is this
people or these children is responsible
about Assad Andrew border and
International Community can he
understand
he lost everyone
single one of his family
he
don't know anything about this and they
don't care about this and I'll just
forget about this I want this patient to
survive and as well as the injured there
are the earthquake babies born
prematurely as their terrified mothers
scrambled to safety
Fatima weighs a kilo the feeding syringe
next to her is almost as big as she is
every movement she makes however small
is welcomed by the nurses it shows a
fighting Spirit she will need to survive
being born in the midst of an earthquake
and in a country at War
the number of babies like Fatima
violently arriving early into the world
because of the earthquakes has jumped by
50 according to the doctors here and
with four ventilators being shared
amongst about 20 little ones the chances
are many of these babies will not
survive to see life outside these wards
do you think you can save any of them or
is it just too difficult right now
we'll try our best to save all of them
but right now the border gate to Turkey
is closed and it won't be enough to
depend on just the equipment we have
here
the hospitals in Italy which have been
bombed and rebuilt and bombed again are
now affected by earthquake damage with
Wards emptied and patients shifted
many are too scared to stay inside their
homes and even hospital patients
including children are still so fearful
of more Tremors and aftershocks they
prefer to sleep outside
the earthquakes like the war have
impacted the most vulnerable in Northern
Syria and visiting doctors from Canada
said the UN should be ashamed over the
lives lost
this is because of the latest Forest
if the response was early we could have
saved many lives this is simple you
don't I think you understand that you
don't have to physician or surgeon to
understand that a crush injury if you
wait four or five days the outcome is
going to be very bad and even those with
Lionheart hadn't been able to defy the
politicking a few hours after we left
idlib arsalan the little boy who
survived the war and then the earthquake
lost his fight for Life killed by what
the doctors believe were bureaucratic
battles Alex Crawford Sky News in idlib
Northwest Syria